the buy underway interesting enough that
earlier day on social media
britt baker told me she had a doctor's
note that said that rebel
not reba could not compete in this match
so but tony was written on her own
letterhead of course i was hurt
she's the one who wrote the doctor's
notes okay she's a dentist
she's not a doctor and i said
okay i'll send it to tony i don't know i
i don't know what she's up to but she's
always seemingly up to something
oh she's scheming and she's got a mic in
her hand so let's
hear from the good doctor herself and
where is rebel
all right all right as i was saying
earlier today my partner and assistant
reba was brutally attacked by nyla rose
and she is injured she cannot compete
and it is
freaking ridiculous that my own doctor's
note signed by
dr brett baker dmd was not enough to
deem her medically
ineligible so
tony khan luckily i didn't have to go
far i looked right across the hall
and found the jaguars team doctor who
agrees with me because we're both
medical professionals come on out reba
[Music]
[Applause]
oh there you see rebel oh my
looking questionably worse for women
reba
is unable to compete tony kahn has
agreed
we need a replacement and doctor knows
best
i have found the perfect replacement and
partner
for myself let's clear the stage
go ahead justin
[Applause]
wow look at this it is
[Applause]
the standout fan favorite in the first
round of the japanese side
of the aw women's world championship
eliminator tournament bracket
he wants a sensation in that tournament
and listen to the fans that are chanting
her name
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
well tony the jacksonville children's
choir
[Music]
[Applause]
with a 20-minute time limit introducing
the opponents first from the graveyards
of tijuana
got a couple of champions at least
former champions on the other side
excalibur
yeah for the fans who are not familiar
with making though she
was in a group that's right she was a an
idol a
a pop idol in japan a singing and
dancing group she was fired for being
unpopular so she made the transition for
wrestling of course
really yeah
and protecting partner from shinagawa
city japan
[Music]
and you mentioned how the the riho and
thunder rose are two
former champions thunderoffs and former
nwa women's world champion reho
the first ever aew women's world
champion all four of these women were
also participants
in that world championship eliminator
tournament that culminated last
wednesday night on dynamite when ryo
mizunami
won the final round match over nila rose
and she will be facing hikaru shida
tonight
ryo mizunami versus shida tonight with
the aew women's world championship
on the line at revolution on
pay-per-view revolution shaping up to be
the number one wrestling paint review
thus far in 2021
and here we go well you know that
that rebel is glad that she's not in
this match yeah most certainly
and uh the fans very glad to see makito
and a lot of a lot of shared history
actually between all four
of these uh these competitors riho and
makito had faced off in tokyo joshi pro
only one time in a singles match rio got
the victory there but rijo and brick
baker
actually uh brit baker was riho's first
challenger for the aew women's world
championship all the way back on
october 17th 2019.
[Applause]
brick going for the break there paul
paul turner obliges you now and and the
fans are not appreciating that but the
fact is is that uh
rio which is a little bit too quick for
here in the early moments
oh well that'll change things right
swift kick to the guts
drops rijo dr britt baker with the
advantage
peppering rijo with a shot sending her
into the ropes reho
cartwheels through dropkick takes down
bret baker rio building up steam
and another dropkick point for a female
wrestler small as she is she's got a lot
of power behind those drop kicks yeah
rijo has perfected the art
of maximizing her force maximizing her
impact
she is the most experienced competitor
in this match with
almost 15 years of in-ring experience at
only 23 years of age
an amazing stat it really is here we go
maki did only five
foot three and 25 years of age look at
her
itochan the cutest in the world facing
off
with thunder rosa this is not the first
time these two women have met
what in the world i i didn't expect that
well makihito i mean the reason she she
flirts so well in pro wrestling is
because
she really adapted to it she has she she
has a course uh
course command of the english language
let's say if you've ever followed her on
social media
right and uh the pro wrestling fans in
ddt her home promotion japan they really
really took to that
and uh look at this thunder rosa looking
for a fujiwara armbar here early on
so fundamentally sound as thunderosa
[Applause]
you obviously we obviously have known
the problem between thunderosa and brit
baker
oh we certainly have brit is uh brits
has
had thunder rosa firmly in her sights
for for months now saying she doesn't
belong
in aew that uh there's not a place for
outsiders
and she's tried everything that she can
to drive thunder ross out but that
only seems to make rosa come back even
harder
shoulder tackles i don't think that's a
good strategy for makita
neither competitor giving ground thunder
rosa big
right elbow strike look at her tell her
lay it in
whoa oh
got what she asked for
and thunder rosa just laying in a
barrage of elbow strikes
rijo cheering on oh no
[Music]
erupted in tears
she is so shrewd
[Applause]
ito and thunder rosa that's what you
call flare for the
dramatic man oh
that's that's not gonna work i'm telling
you i'm not against linda rosa
i mentioned this is not the first time
these two have met thunder rosa actually
defeated
makito on january 5th 2020 in tokyo
japan
for the tokyo yoshi pro international
princess title a title that rosa
was forced to vacate a little later on
oh ito
with the grand naniwa esque bulldog out
of the corner
[Music]
and maki ito asks who's the cutest in
the world
well she's got she's got a contagious
smile
[Applause]
yeah it is she is laying in
shots to thunder rosa uh-oh
thunderosa though not taking too kindly
to it
and ito goes down face first on that top
turnbuckle pad
[Applause]
tony have to remind everybody coming up
at the top of the hour it is aew's
revolution
live on pay-per-view br live or fight tv
around the world wherever you are you
cannot miss it
revolution live at the top of the hour
rio with the cover here
two now man so close and the great devil
team razor thin
kick out there by makito great teamwork
and you know these uh
makito and dr brick baker
have not spent that much time together
as a team but neither has
rehoe and rosa oh no they certainly
haven't and makito just
44 hours ago covered here by rijo
no wow another very close kick out
just 44 hours ago ito was competing in
japan and tokyo joshi pro
in their uh their max heart tournament
she actually teamed up with yamashita
covered here by rosa ito kicks out
and makito and miyu yamashita made it to
the final round
of that tournament so ito wrestled twice
in one night
or one afternoon in a high stakes
tournament
but rijo and thunder rosa looking great
here one two no
and i've taken that flight from japan
here to the east coast
man that's a long time in an airplane
yeah i think 18 plus
hours yesterday for makito to get here
and big elbow strike there from ito
rijo and makito teeing off on one
another
boy that one found its mark
neither woman wants to give ground here
center of the ring
[Applause]
rijo just saying give me what you got
etho oh
and brit barking orders oh look at that
sweeping out the leg of rijo she tried
to do it earlier didn't catch her foot
but that time she caught her and yeah i
don't think
rijo noticed it earlier but right now
and thunder rosa inside the ring
she inadvertently has uh paul did you
see what rebel did she just helped
yeah brit throw rijo back into the ring
so seemingly she's not as bad as we
thought and of course
we knew that uh-oh
this is the kokeshi the big diving
headbutt from the famously hard-headed
idol
she misses the kokeshi
and wisely though ito makes the tag out
to dr britt baker
this is where britt's at her best when
she's got the momentum going her way
look at that cravat and when she's got
the upper hand where she knows how to
lay him in
she is vicious and i know that for a
fact and
bret getting directly into the face of
thunder rosa
trying to trying to do as much as she
can to undermine
the tag team cohesion between rosa and
rijo
brit voted the most improved wrestler in
the sport recently
and she's also one of the more
intelligent as obviously
with her degree in depth here just a
two-count
yes she is a she is a dmda
practicing yes dmd
that now has rio on the
bottom rope just driving that center
come on rebel just once again engaging
in some
extracurriculars out there if rebel
cannot participate why is she even out
there i mean if maybe she should be back
with the
well if she's cheerleading now makito
with the snapmare pulling rijo up and
wow
really wrenching back there
thunder rosa knows that she needs to tag
in
rijo finally getting the boot on the
bottom rope to force the break
she's not breaking nowhere well finally
she did makito taking full advantage
she's got a temper too man she's she's
got that beautiful smile and she's
she's a delight to watch but man you can
tell that you just don't want to get her
upset
yeah she is uh oh oh makito
goes face oh gets hung out to dry over
the top rope the guillotine there by
rijo
makito staggered rijo
up to the top diving cross body
she covers one two no
had a trouble getting that leg hooked or
maybe she would have won it
and coming up at the top of the hour
it's aew's revolution of course
the big casino tag team royale part of
our massive event tonight
pay-per-view br live or fight tv you
don't want to miss it
30 men 15 teams all competing for a shot
at the ew world tag team championship
every team every man for himself in that
one that's coming up later on man
the winner gets a shot at the world tag
team championship thunder rosa picking
up right where she left off with dr
britt
banker oh the exclamation point
draftkick in the corner
and paul turner's got to check in
because britt may be out here
that found it smart double underhook
butterfly suplex this time
from thunder rosa on brit thunder rosa
pulling brick towards the center of the
ring
it's one of the best rivalries greatest
rivalries in all of wrestling right now
grit baker and thunder rosa thunder rosa
build up ahead of steam sits out with
the scent don
one two and tony it is it is a
tremendous rivalry and it's a rivalry
that only seems to grow in intensity
week after week
they definitely do not like each other
they come from entirely different
backgrounds
as we know oh look at this brit
looking to escape out of the back door
grabs the waist locked under rosa
rammed in the corner edo tags herself in
great move by britt get her in that
corner and now
diving back elbow with the assist from
dr britt baker
ito sensed under rosie sling blade
great teamwork here and brynn wasn't
even the legal person in the ring
and now makito looking for the kokeshi
and she hits it
driving all the wind out of thunder rosa
ito covers to no thunder ropes just too
strong even though that
headbutt was on target right in the
midsection right of the breadbasket
oh but talk about the bread basket kick
to that bread mask gets stunned by
thunder rosa
makes the heads up tag out to rijo and
rijo once again goes right for brit
baker there you go
and that's going to bring brit in oh boy
did it ever
let's frost get the enzy geary there by
thunder rosa ito
the boot to the back of thunderosa maki
ito
building up ahead of oh ran right into
the boot
she catches the lariat attempt vaults
off the middle that top the swinging ddt
super delphin eats your heart out
great move by rosa to roll out of the
ring
dunder rosa rolled out of the ring ito
having to pull her back towards center
uh-oh could be thinking
the diving kokeshi
[Applause]
ito up to the top
oh nobody home the pool is empty
but rio picks ito up
oh the knee strike roll reversal into
the single leg crab
she's got it shade's got it
makito wrenching back on rio tony if she
picks up the victory here this would be
something of an upset
she's gonna tap the the arm is up no
she didn't do it makito is never beating
rijo in her career
what a statement it would be to do so
here tonight
on the revolution by end she can't get
too frustrated now she got to go back to
the attack again
antonio you have to wonder is exhaustion
setting in she had that long
trans-pacific flight yesterday
and before that had two high-profile
tournament matches at tokyo joshi pro
how much does maki ito have left in the
tank be a huge win for herbie a huge win
for dr britt baker against her
the woman she hates more than anything
oh don't do that
veto blocked it with their head
the kokeshi blocking the elbow strike
budget oh she stepped into it and rijo
absolutely stunned both
competitors stunned
so much coming up tonight at the top of
the hour this jam-packed revolution
pay-per-view
event street fight man that is it sting
back in the ring
brett after the air raid crash covers
here no thunder rosa breaks it up
and tony that street fight sting and
darby allen versus
team taz's brian cage and ricky starks
it is going to be wild available on
pay-per-view pr live
and fight tv in just a few minutes
here we a lot of go
here the roll up almost a two count
brit takes down thunder rosa great move
brit banker
and now has the back slide locked in and
she's got it hooked in deep
no they almost pinned her great
backslide at the time
ddt just spiked under rosa
brit covers oh santa rosa counters into
the crucifix
this has been a highly technical
exchange tony it really has both
these ladies very well versed in this
sport
uh-oh now look at this rebel dropped the
crutch and now she's up on
she seems okay to me
[Applause]
oh brit oh britain rebel meeting in the
mines there
[Applause]
watch out from behind now thunder rosa
death valley driver i think she's out
one here comes
oh no jokes in the nick of time
the last possible second machido makes
the break
and rijo on the opposite side of the
ring just dove on machido
and now thunder rosa center of the ring
she's looking for that fire thunder
driver brit
counters out front right on the money
my death watch the crush but referee
didn't see it and knocked her out
one two oh my god
bridge is stolen
[Music]
baker victorious here tonight on the
revolution buy-in
but speaking of revolution our main
event tonight the aew world championship
will be on the line an exploding
barbed wire death match kenny omega
versus john moxley let's see how we got
here